[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el
nuevo presidente de perú pedro castillo
presento y juramento su nuevo gabinete
de ministros un gabinete salpicado de
controversias desacuerdos y rechazo por
parte de los ciudadanos principalmente
en contra del primer ministro guido
bellido quien es criticado por su apoyo
al grupo guerrillero sendero luminoso y
al gobierno de cuba para revisar este
tema quiero saludar en este momento a
josé tello él es analista político josé
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 porque generó tanto
descontento y críticas esta conformación
del gabinete del presidente castillo son
personas indicadas para sus respectivos
cargos
perfectamente todo muchas gracias por la
invitación y si efectivamente en el país
estamos algo preocupados en general
porque este es el discurso de asunción
al cargo el reciente castillo 28 julio
se espera nunca viene tener el mayor
consenso que involucre a diferentes
fuerzas políticas principalmente de
izquierdas porque que nada no el
gobierno de la izquierda en el país sin
embargo se vio que habían algunos
integrantes que más allá de no tener el
perfil técnico necesario también eran
personas muy radicales en cuanto a la
tendencia de izquierda no se vio en un
primer momento en mi cara moderada eso
obviamente voy avanzando hacia la
elección de un ministro de economía y
finanzas de izquierda a moderado como
pedro francke algo que sin lugar a dudas
ha bajado un poco la temperatura en
torno a lo que ocurre con el gabinete de
el presidente del castillo sin embargo
subsisten los cuestionamientos respecto
algunas personas
el señor maravillo el señor silva el
señor ciro galvis hay cuestionamientos
en lo que se refiere a su tendencia
ideológica radial o también a su
performance técnico ahora josé llama
mucho la atención la baja participación
femenina esto en aras de la equidad de
género un punto que también le ha valido
señalamientos el presidente castillo
algo interesante por ejemplo que se ha
analizado acá es eso efectivamente
respecto por ejemplo del gabinete de
francisco sacarte un supresor tuvo un 58
por ciento de participación de mujeres
dentro del parlamento pero aún dentro
del gabinete o la ratificación pero por
ejemplo estuvo casi por ahí con
alejandro toledo
el señor oyente humana por ejemplo que
fue un presidente de izquierda
más o menos la participación de hombres
en el caso por ejemplo de lo que se
refiere al gabinete de hoy en tu mala
era el 78 por ciento la participación de
hombres del gabinete de alejandro toledo
sobre el 88 incluso era bastante alto
del respecto de lo que viene a ser el
programa vigente pero casi no lo supera
largamente sin lugar a dudas eso es algo
en lo cual sí se ha retrocedido pero lo
que tenemos que ver es que los cuadros
por ejemplo que la convocados un cuadro
del interior del país o sea a diferencia
de los demás gabinetes que han tenido
una participación fuerte de personas
de la capital este gabinete incorporó
cuadros el interior del país con lo cual
digamos ha tenido un resorte de
compensación lo cual no del 15 de que
más adelante pues y philip a acostar
hacia una tendencia un gabinete
paritario evidentemente ahora hemos
visto manifestaciones en rechazo a la
elección de guido elegido como primer
ministro
del perú
quienes estamos hablando que representa
bellido en escena política peruana para
ser rechazado de esta manera
a ver en el caso de bellido en ese
cuestionamiento respeto 70 ideológicas
sin lugar a dudas pues existe una
ojeriza marcada en torno a eso porque él
está sin divertido por apología y
terrorismo y es a razón de unas
declaraciones que dio donde exaltó la
figura de tiki lagos una terrorista
sanguinaria
ultimada en los años 80 ella estuvo
digamos en los inicios y en la época
dura el terrorismo
recordemos que eso se dio principalmente
durante el gobierno de fernando belaunde
terry y alan garcía pérez entonces
es una cuestión que ha generado mucho
malestar porque es muy sensible ese tema
acá en el perú hay que ser claros de que
muchos por lo menos desde el parlamento
en esto como una provocación y es más o
sea lo que esperan y que nos ayuda la
confianza
o sea gracias por su tiempo su análisis
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 que
tenga usted un feliz resto de día hasta
aquí 5 minutos que van continúan con
nosotros
[Música]